hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear movie review series and yes i'm
finally getting around to talking about
this movie i feel like i've been
kind of sleeping on it all this time
this one i've been wanting to talk about
for a long time ever since i started
doing this series so let's get into it
so
the babadook
it is an australian psychological horror
film
and when it came out back in 2014
it made a really really big splash with
critics and with like a lot of horror
fans and honestly to this day it still
turns up on a lot of people's like best
horror movies of the century so far
lists including mine a matter of fact
now because there was so much hype
surrounding it um this one and i feel
like it follows which came out like
around a similar time kind of had the
same kind of thing like oh there's this
new kind of you know these kind of new
or original fresh voices in horror so
they both got like super super over
hyped because of that there was a pretty
predictable backlash um against both
movies but against the babadook in
particular uh with some people thinking
oh the movie is boring or it's annoying
or it's not scary or i've even seen a
few people say oh it's not even a horror
movie which i don't really understand
that criticism
but whatever i mean i get people like
different things and
you know i'm not gonna get my panties
all in a bunch about it because i have
better things to do with my life uh
another thing that i just learned
recently while i was uh watching
re-watching the movie and doing research
about it is that and this is very
amusing due to some very weird thing i'm
assuming it's like kind of some kind of
mistake where the movie was at one point
put into the lgbtq plus section on
netflix somebody took a screenshot of
that and because of it the community
sort of like embraced the babadook like
the character of the babadook is sort of
like an icon and they started like
making memes about it and there's like
little signs like if you go to pride
parade there's always like some signs of
it so they started making kind of like
all these hilarious little things with
the character sort of like embracing it
which i thought was like super funny so
i first saw the babadook i think back in
2015
and i really loved it and i kind of made
a note to come back to it like for a
second watch
and then recently just a couple months
ago i was browsing through uh the
bargain horror bin like at fye if you
don't have fye where you are it's kind
of like a store it's usually in malls
and they kind of sell movies and music
and merch having to do with movies and
music like t-shirts and you know pop
figures and things like that so while i
was looking through their five dollar
dvd section i found a copy of the
babadook and i was like oh well look at
that five dollars and i've been wanting
to rewatch this anyway like for the show
so i picked it up so this movie is the
feature film debut of a woman named
jennifer kent who was actually an actor
for about 20 years before
sort of pivoting into directing
now how she actually learned to
to do directing i guess like other than
you know just being an actor and being
on sets and knowing about it from that
angle
what she did was that when she decided
to go into directing she contacted uh
the very controversial danish director
lars von trier and asked to assist on
his 2003 movie dogville which is very
good if you haven't seen it nicole
kidman isn't it uh he agreed and so she
went and sort of like got her education
on the job so to speak
incidentally uh jennifer kent also
directed the 2018 movie the nightingale
which i've heard is fantastic but i
haven't seen it yet it's really really
high up on my to watch list i don't
think it's exactly a horror movie but
it's supposed to be like really
harrowing and [ __ ] up so i'm looking
forward to watching that as well now she
had actually made a short film back in
2005 which was called monster
and it was sort of like a small scale
version of what would eventually become
the babadook she started working on the
script for that back in about 2009 and
went through like a bunch of different
iterations of it
now from the first she seemed to have
had the idea
that she wanted this movie sort of like
not only to be an exploration of certain
aspects of motherhood that weren't
usually featured in horror films or
really in films in general
and she also kind of wanted the visuals
of the movie to hearken back to like the
silent film days uh in particular the
work of uh george melies um you know who
did a lot of trick films and like silent
movies back in the old days in the
german expressionist movement she
actually initially wanted to shoot the
babadook in black and white but
eventually that that ended up not
happening also she was real into like
the films like roman polanski and david
lynch and stuff like that so she wanted
that kind of like vibe to it as well in
the story we're following a very
frazzled single mother named amelia
now she's played by essie davis who
honestly should have gotten an oscar
nomination for this uh if the oscars
were in the habit of like giving
nominations to people in horror movies i
mean i know there's some exceptions they
have like gotten better in the last few
years but generally genre films uh are
usually not recognized but she
completely should have been because she
was [ __ ] great in this oh i want to
say too that that actually um essie
davis was friends with jennifer kent
like they went to the same acting school
and were like friends for the whole time
so i thought that was kind of neat too
so seven years prior to the events of
the film
amelia's husband oscar was killed in
this horrifying car crash while the
couple were in route to the hospital
like amelia was having their baby like
their first child sam uh but oscar
obviously died and didn't make it so
amelia it seems has never really come to
terms with the loss of her husband and
she's kind of like buried it deep down
within herself she doesn't really want
to talk about it she doesn't want to
move on with her life even though it's
been almost seven years
she also harbors this really deep but
seemingly unconscious resentment toward
her son samuel essentially kind of
blaming him for killing her husband
because you know it was kind of i guess
she sees it as like oh it was his fault
that we were in the car at that time you
know that's when we went to labor so
she's obviously it's not rational but
you know it's an understandable emotion
to have uh one of the things that this
manifest says too is that she actually
has never let samuel
celebrate his birthday on the actual day
that he was born because that was the
same day that her husband died too so
she just can't face it so usually they
have like a joint party with him and his
cousin whose birthdays are sort of
around the same time so he always has
his birthday like on his cousin's
birthday so that's how they've kind of
like worked it out so the kid who is now
almost seven years old it's like
approaching his birthday like it's only
a few weeks away
he
senses his mother's hatred of him and
this sort of like makes him act out in
increasingly destructive ways i guess
you'd say like you know he screams a lot
you know he's like always look at the
bag like shrieking at the top of his
lungs um he builds weapons
and takes them to school he you know
shoots off weapons in the house and like
breaks windows like [ __ ] like that at
one point he pushes his cousin out of a
tree house and like breaks her nose
after he after she um like teases him
about not having a dad that kind of [ __ ]
now amelia is offered a few lifelines in
order to sort of like help her deal with
this demon spawn that she has
um for example she has like an elderly
neighbor named grace and she's very
caring and very supportive and watches
the kids sometimes and like keeps an eye
on him and things like that
and the school authorities um after
after samuel like gets in trouble for
bringing like a like a weapon of some
kind like to school they try to like
but you know they try to like talk to
her like work with her about it they're
like look um you know he's we want to
help him but he's kind of like dangerous
to the other kids so maybe the best
thing to do we should have a compromise
we can isolate him from the other
children but give him a tutor like
one-on-one like to work with him for his
behavioral problems but amelia really
seems defensive um and she's kind of
like reluctant to
really like unburden herself i guess i
think it's because she doesn't really
want to be seen as a failure like as a
mother this dynamic is kind of
highlighted by her little bit
contentious relationship with her sister
who is the mother of the cousin because
the sister absolutely does judge amelia
for being like you know why haven't you
moved on with your life like what are
you doing like what why how are you
mothering that kid the kid's a brat blah
blah blah and she doesn't really want to
listen to amelia's problems like she's
kind of over it and she won't even like
come to the house because she's like i'm
not being anywhere around that kid like
he sucks and all this other kind of
stuff so it's super not helpful she's
not really getting a lot of support from
her family at least in that you know in
that respect so into this kind of
cauldron
of angst
there appears on a bookshelf in
samuel's room this mysterious
handcrafted little children's book
called mr babadook
amelia isn't really sure where it came
from supposedly but she starts reading
it to samuel like he picks it out and
she starts reading it to him one night
and she only gets a few pages in before
she realizes uh that this book is really
not appropriate for a six-year-old child
uh because it's about this really
unsettling
monster
with this kind of like really spooky
like white face these creepy white eyes
like this big smile with like these
creepy teeth um this kind of slouchy top
hat this big black cloak and these long
like razory fingers
so the monster keeps like wanting to be
let in
and
seemingly wants to kind of like
terrorize their little uh their small
little family there now even though
amelia stops reading it before the story
gets too upsetting uh samuel is still
kind of traumatized by the story and
starts to become convinced that the
babadook is real which again kind of
like amps up his whole anxiety thing and
like he starts building more weapons
like to fight the monster to protect his
mom and stuff like that so over the
course of the story samuel's behavior
like starts to become worse and worse as
he becomes more terrified of the monster
and amelia kind of also starts to sort
of lose her grip on sanity as the kids
antics sort of like drive her past the
breaking point uh she also begins to see
the monster
and honestly i'm not gonna lie uh the
monster is still creepy as [ __ ] like the
design of the monster is like really
cool especially in the way that it kind
of like skitters around like it almost
seems like handmade like it's a puppet
made out of paper and it just you know
the way that it moves is like really
like uncanny and like otherworldly and i
really do love that also the voice that
he has because he calls on the phone
once and he like whispers in her ear and
stuff is like really croaky and that's
like really unnerving as well um so at
one stage near like right at the
beginning of the third act of the movie
amelia seemingly becomes possessed by
the babadook and that sort of like
causes her to act upon these murderous
impulses that she has uh she kills the
little doggie so you know just know that
going in i could have done without that
but i know that's why they did you know
how i am about like don't leave the
kitties and puppies alone like in the
movies horror movies they always want to
kill the cute little animals i'm like
kill all the kids you want it's like
just goddamn it just leave the [ __ ]
animals alone but yeah the dog doesn't
get killed in this one but you know that
was gonna happen
so she does kill the dog but she gets
like all [ __ ] murdery and [ __ ] like
that but you know it's all kind of
resolved in the end the monster isn't
really so much defeated as it's sort of
like contained and managed
as amelia kind of learns to come to
terms with these complex emotions that
ultimately spawned the monster so as
with many monster movies uh the
character of the babadook
is kind of like playing two roles in the
sense that it's a monster but it's also
like a representation
on the one hand he does seem to be a
real monster uh both amelia and samuel
can see him and he does seem to have
like some impacts like in the real world
on the other hand he's also a creation
of amelia's sort of like simmering
animosity toward her child and the
unresolved feelings she has about her
husband's death it's not so much that
the monster represents grief i think
it's
more represents her
the unspoken hatred that she has toward
her kid and her guilt at feeling that
way because she doesn't think she's
supposed to feel that way a criticism
that i see a lot of this movie is that
people felt cheated because the monster
turned out to be quote unquote not real
but i don't really think that's the case
and it also kind of seems to be like
missing the point a little bit
i mean you could also argue that the
ghosts that jack nicholson sees in the
shining
also aren't real
but are simply avatars for his sort of
like raging alcoholism and his uh
antagonism toward his family but really
nobody complained about that the way i
see it i mean the babadook is absolutely
real i mean even though it's implied
that amelia created the book herself
like there's a couple scenes where she
has you know what looks like charcoal
like on her hands and things like that
she did model the creature after her
son's like magician get up like with the
hat and the cloak and everything and she
later sort of like personifies the
monster
as she kind of gives into her own hatred
and essentially becomes the monster i'm
kind of of the opinion that the sort of
depth of her hostility toward the kid
brought the monster quite literally like
into the world and the thing about it is
a lot of horror movies kind of play with
this trope so i don't know why people
singled out the babadook and complained
about that like in particular because a
lot of horror movies do that but again
whatever another very common grape uh
that i see with this movie is that
probably the most common gripe i feel
like is that samuel is an annoying
little [ __ ] who you would really like to
drop kick into next week now i will
agree with that that is absolutely true
but again
that's absolutely the point of that
character
at the beginning of the movie you're
actually supposed to sympathize with
amelia
um as she has to deal with this
incorrigible little hell beast that's
like running around her house
um you know i'm not a parent myself but
i've known enough parents that have told
me that there are lots of times when
your kid is like misbehaving that you
actively dislike this child and you feel
kind of like bad about it so i really do
love that this movie
took this very common but also a little
bit taboo emotion that a lot of people
have um and sort of like did sort of
like an exploration of it now so the
viewer is supposed to think that samuel
sucks and to want to strangle the brat
right i mean that's kind of what you're
supposed to feel about him
but then slowly as the story unfolds
you start to realize that samuel is just
a little kid i mean he's just like a
vulnerable little six-year-old kid and
even though he's awful
he's only responding to the way his
mother treats him in the only way that
he knows how to respond because again
he's just a little kid so when amelia
goes kind of like full-on monster toward
the end your sympathies have kind of
like shifted towards samuel as he sort
of like falls into the crosshairs and
you realize you've been sympathizing
with a woman who is gonna strangle her
own child you know what i mean which is
probably not a place you want to be and
samuel actually does become more
sympathetic as the movie goes on because
you you see that he actually does love
his mother and he wants to protect her
but he's only acting that way because of
the way that because of this kind of
monster that's within her that he senses
and he senses that he's in danger from
her and he doesn't really know how to
respond to that other than by like
acting out now i have also seen the
argument made that the kids behavior was
like too over the top i will note though
that i grew up around lots and lots of
kids i don't have any kids my own but
like i said i grew up around lots and
lots of kids like i have several
siblings and tons of cousins and uh my
parents ran a daycare at one point so i
was around a lot of little kids all the
time i've actually been first-hand
witness to a handful of children who
acted absolutely the same way that
samuel does in this movie i kind of feel
like nowadays that would maybe be
diagnosed as maybe adhd or you know
maybe even like some aspects of autism
or something like that so i don't really
think it's over the top in particular
like i said you're supposed to hate the
kids so if it's a little bit over the
top that's why although this film does
seem somewhat divisive like in the
horror community i guess i'm in the camp
of people who really really loved it i
mean i really loved it had just these
arresting visuals like that monster
looked so cool like it was like a paper
puppet and like the way it kind of like
moved around the ceiling and stuff like
so great like so creepy and it just had
this really great like all-around sort
of like eerie vibe like very cool very
shadowy very silent movie-esque i love
that kind of stuff and i really did like
the sort of metaphorical deep dive that
it did into
these complicated feelings that that
some mothers have uh toward their
offspring um the acting in this is also
phenomenal and it really did sell the
escalating horror between amelia and her
son like as the monster got more and
more powerful i mean not everyone is
into this movie and that's okay
but i really think this is easily one of
my favorite horror movies of the past
several years so whether you agree or
disagree let me know in the comments and
we'll have a discussion about it and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye